trong đội viên đe bisou, ngày hôm 7,5 đưa chúng tưởng hóc ta ít ta á lên làm tổng thủ trình tiếp,
chỉ muốn ngày sau khi lực lợi này lật độ chính quyền dần sử, chứa thời điểm công bộ kết quả bầu cử.
Bộ ngoài rào sinh gán xác nhận, tuung tổng thống Umaroo embalo đại được người sang đã ca,
theo sự thu sẽ quả nhỏ cộng đồng kích tế, các của gia tầy P, Echo Wasch,
nhỏ m đảo trình từ sức là bộ trị quy quân sử khó khủng chất tự,
nói họ bục phải cán thiệp đẹg ngán trạm của Amyu Vai Bất Own,
liên quan tởi giới trị trị và cám mạng lưỡi mà tổ ý, giù không gử dụng giả mạnh trưởng.
Trong là xuất hiện đầu tiên trên chuyên niệm cuối ra, tổng thống lắm thời,
ín ta á nói, nên rất trủ đam bị thông tổng, ông cảm kết quả trị chuyển tiếp,
cảo giải trị một năm trước khi tổng thình cờ,
liên mình cho ông, Echo Wasch và liên mình cho phi đồng lọt lên á đảo trình.
Thiu cầu trạm từ giòn trong embalo và cho phép tiếp tục kiểm phíau,
trong dịch bến này, ở viên rồi lọt phát nào đồ đi á,
cáo buộc ông embalo giữ mạng kịch đảo trình kể chi hoán tổ cờ.
Thủ đối bí sông, ngày hôm nay mình bỏ tiên án với liên tình chà dài đọc,
nhiều cờ hàng vàng hạn đảo cờ,
một số cuộc tụ tập nhỏ bị giải tám mắc rơi cây, nhưng chơi khi nhạc thương vâm,
kể tự khi đập lập khỏi bộ đồng nhàn,
mình chỉ trăm bệ vinh tư,
ghi này bí sâu là cũng ra thủ nhỏ bất,
on giết tầy phy khi đa rất nhiều lần sảy ra đảo trình.